okay so isn't that a form of racism  someone to say to you you can't think  like that you're you know you must think  like this a white person telling you  i've had it all my life you know it's  the left tend to think that being an  ethnic minority i have to vote for  left-wing parties i have to hold  left-wing opinions this idea that anyone  that's not white belongs to one  homogeneous group and they almost vote  like think alike and talk alike i find  that racist that's very patronizing  because we're individuals and we all  have different opinions different  thoughts different religions  why should we subscribe to the left's  narrative on what we think and i think  it comes down to control and power  because if the left say we are the party  for your particular demographic you have  to stay in that box and anyone in that  box for us that's how they get into  power